Hello there!
Ms. Coffee Bean is here to explain PET,
no the other PET... no, not this one Ms. Coffee
Bean,
obviously I mean the pattern-exploiting training
kind of PET.
Yeah, who would have guessed it?
It sounds a little complicated but it shows
that any language model, not only a huge one
like GPT-3 is able to learn new tasks from
few training examples.
And this video will explain all about PET
and its sisters iPET and ADAPET, meaning that
in a couple of minutes, you will see how it
is possible for a relatively small language
model, with only a fraction of the size of
GPT-3 to learn a new task from only 32 examples.
That large language models like GPT-3 can
do well on new tasks from really few examples,
has been known since ages ago, in Machine
Learning time…
although in my normal time, it feels like
it was yesterday.
It's important to recapitulate how GPT-3 does
few-shot learning, before explaining the PET
alternative for much smaller models.
With only 32 labelled examples, GPT-3 achieves
almost state of the art results for some SuperGLUE
tasks.
SuperGLUE is THE benchmark for natural language
understanding.
And GPT-3 does it with priming.
Priming means that the models get as input
this whole thing here at once.
This contains first a task description, then
the few labelled examples you have (it’s
few shot learning, so you should have a few
labelled examples) and then the example you
want GPT-3 to label.
But why would THIS ever work?
Well, we remember that GPT-3 is transformer-based
– obviously, and between these tokens there
is self-attention computing the pattern, figuring
out what the next token, so the label, should
be, given all these previous examples as context.
And supposing you have a model like GPT-3
which has already seen virtually the whole
internet, there is a high chance that the
model would pick up the pattern and predict
the right thing.
But the first drawback of this method is that
you usually do not have GPT-3 lying around
to help you.
The second drawback is the limited number
of examples you can give to GPT-3, because
this whole input is parsed into tokens and
unfortunately, the number of tokens cannot
exceed a maximum number.
So the number of examples you can give was
defined already when programming the model
and is constrained by memory and the quadratically
scaling attention.
But do not worry: PET is here to turn the
situation upside down, yeah quite literally,
and promises few-shot learning for normal-sized
models, like BERT or ALBERT… wait.
Since when is BERT normal-sized!?
Anyway, so you want BERT to be able to solve
a certain task, but you have only a small
bunch of annotated data.
So you decide to apply PET and for this, you
need two more ingredients other than few labels:
the so-called pattern and the verbalizer.
For example, if you want to do few-shot learning
on question answering, you should have a few
pairs of questions and answers lying around,
then you are ready
to create patterns.
And not only one, but as many as you can come
up with!
The pattern is a pre-defined template, a so-called
cloze style question, leaving blank space
for inserting the answer or an equivalent
token bearing the same meaning as the answer.
So let’s see an example for one of the patterns.
Keep in mind that the blank should be predicted
later by the model from few examples.
Now the verbalizer comes in: The verbalizer
translates the actual answer of the problem
to a token that has the same meaning as the
actual answer.
It is quite hard to wrap Ms. Coffee Bean’s
head around this, so let’s discuss a little.
One reason for employing the verbalizer is
to reduce the problem complexity, because
various verbalizations like “sure”, “definitely”,
are actually the same thing as saying “yes”.
And just “yes” instead of infinite variations
of it, is easier to understand for the model,
especially in few-shot learning where it has
only few examples to learn from.
Ms. Coffee Bean's guess is that this verbalizer
complicates the paper a bit because of a choice
the authors made in the beginning: If you
constrain the patterns to have the blank at
the end, you can use a GPT-like autoregressive
transformers to predict as many tokens from
left to right as you want to fill in the blank.
But what if you can only think of patterns
with the blank in the middle?
Well, for this case, the authors designed
PET to work with masked language models like
BERT that are exactly designed for inserting
missing things everywhere in the sentence,
not only at the end like GPT.
This makes it possible to constrain the pattern
much less and you can mask out things everywhere,
which is much more flexible.
In the vanilla PET, this space you leave out
can be only one token long as this is the
natural set-up for BERT-like models.
In the follow-up paper, PET also allows for
multiple masked tokens to be predicted one
by one, from left to right.
But vanilla PET did not allow for multiple
tokens first, therefore this verbalizer comes
in as a function that maps more complex outputs
or answers to single label tokens, in a way
that simplifies the many variants the answer
can have.
Okay, so let’s recapitulate.
You have some few labelled instances for a
task that a language model like BERT has not
seen so far, so you decide to teach the model
to solve the task with PET.
Therefore you create patterns with gaps where
the model should hopefully insert the right
answer and fill the patterns with your examples.
You have more patterns and you can’t decide
which pattern to take?
Well for PET, the more the better: take all
of them and go on with the PET algorithm by
training your masked language model for each
pattern on all examples.
So if you have 3 patterns, you should train
at least 3 language models.
But in practice you will end up with something
like 9, since training a language models on
so little data as 32 examples is very unstable.
So yeah, you should train more than one model
per pattern, but it does not take long on
so few examples, therefore this ensembling
procedure is feasible.
Then the PET recipe says, you should use this
ensemble of language models as teachers to
annotate a set of unlabeled examples and use
these silver labels to train a regular sequence
classifier which should be your final model
for making predictions on the new task.
Hm… what was this training setting called?
Ah yes, distillation, yes it's distillation
indeed!
And if you do this iteratively, gradually
increasing the size of the unlabeled dataset
based on the labels of the previous iteration,
you have iPET!
By doing this training and automatic annotating
procedure iteratively, you hope to gradually
increase the quality of the teacher models
and your silver data.
What if in some iteration everything deviates
and you end up generating nonsense in the
end?
Hmm…
Well, in any case:
So the gist of step 2 is to make gradient
updates, but because you do this on very little
data, the training is unstable.
Therefore you need an ensemble of these unstable
models from which you distill, but for distillation
you also have to gather unlabeled data somehow.
But does one always have task-specific unlabeled
data lying around?
No, therefore different authors propose a
follow-up on PET called ADAPET.
ADAPET takes the distillation steps away,
but how?
Why should a language model ever converge
with unstable fine-tuning on just 32 examples?
Well, by introducing more fine-grained losses!
In PET the language model is allowed only
to consider task label tokens for the blank
space, meaning that there will be gradient
updates only for the label tokens.
So if we would list all the words the language
model knows, then only the labels, like "yes"
or "no" would be adapted to the new task,
but not the representations for other words
like “calendar”.
To alleviate of this, ADAPET considers every
word or token of the vocabulary for the blank.
It reinforces the correct label and pushes
the other words further away, adapting representations
of all words in the vocabulary.
Ms. Coffee Bean’s intuition behind this
would be that if one wants to do few-shot
learning with gradient updates and no distillation,
the model should be given more chances to
adapt for the new task.
She does not think it would be enough to change
only the representations for the class tokens
and hope that the dynamic representation computation
by attention does all the rest.
At least not when one does not start with
GPT-3 as a base model in the first place,
because GPT-3 does not even need any gradient
updates for few-shot learning.
Therefore it seems like a good solution to
engineer many ways for the model to make the
right changes.
Question: in which cases would it make perhaps
the wrong changes?
Ms. Coffee Bean’s assumption is in cases
where the original training of the base model,
for example BERT, is very far away from the
task one needs to learn.
She would not expect PET to enable few-shot
learning for HTML code classification, if
the base model had never seen HTML code before.
In contrast to HTML code, SuperGLUE is relatively
close to what BERT has seen already.
In any case, another approach is to give the
model as much information as you can, so to
give the model the same few examples you already
have, but from a different perspective.
And that is exactly ADAPET’s second addition
to PET: it adds one more task (and loss) in
a multi-task setting.
It optimizes not only for the answer, but
also for predicting the right context given
the correct answer.
This is valuable, especially for few-shot
learning, to give the model the chance to
learn as much about the task as possible.
While PET tried to tackle few-shot learning
by distillation, in other words by automatically
annotating unlabeled data and the learning
from it, ADAPET adds refined and more detailed
and informative losses instead of distillation.
Cool that was it, now you know about PET,
iPET and ADAPET!
Check out the experiments in the papers, where
you basically see how PET and its variations
can make ALBERT… wait, who is ALBERT.
Ms. Coffee Bean, do you have anything to confess?
No, ALBERT is just another BERT variant.
So, I was saying that you will see PET applied
on ALBERT, which is a much smaller model than
GPT-3 and can also lead to impressive few-shot
results on SuperGLUE after seeing just 32
labelled examples.
For more on this, check out the papers linked
below!
So to wrap up, here is the take-home message
from Ms. Coffee Bean: PET enables few-shot
learning by distillation from an ensemble
of models trained on patterns capturing the
task as a cloze task, which is just a fancy
way of saying “fill in the gaps”.
iPET enables the patterns to capture more
tokens than just only one and then ADAPET
simplifies pet by using patterns, but replacing
distillation with better losses.
I hope you see the pattern here, where one
important step in few-shot learning, has become
to engineer patterns or prompts.
Very much like when priming GPT-3, you still
have to think a little about framing your
task to present it to the model.
So, no wonder a new job description was created,
called prompt engineering!
But the difference between GPT-3 few-shot
learning and PET-enabled few-shot learning
is the following: When priming GPT-3, you
do not need further training or gradient updates.
I honestly do not know why it is called few-shot
LEARNING, because there is no learning anymore,
just dynamic computation of a new label given
the existing examples as context.
With a model that has seen the whole internet
already, it is ok to expect this to work.
GPT-3’s few-shot application broadness comes
in Ms. Coffee Bean’s humble opinion from
the variation of data it has already seen
and we do not think anything trained on less
data variance can compete with that aspect.
But with PET, one does indeed few-shot learning,
because it needs little training, gradient
updates, LEARNING, and it enables few-shot
learning with much smaller models than GPT-3
that did not see the same amount of data variation.
But one question remains:
How far can PET go, apart from the SuperGLUE
benchmark?
Hihi, okay, bye!